c'est le shoot d'adrénaline du vendredi
soir
durant deux heures et malgré la fatigue
ces sportifs doivent rester concentrés
pour ne pas oublier une seule consigne
et là voilà je travaille ok je l'emmène
et je me mets sur lui Caro MMA
l'ensemble du corps est une cible
c'est un sport qui mélange plus de
discipline donc il est à la fois des
disciplines de préhension donc de saisie
de percussion et des disciplines de
projection donc on va cumuler forcément
les traumatismes de chaque discipline
des traumatismes de percussions par
exemple c'est souvent des Bleus les
traumatismes de projection ça va être
des luxations des choses comme ça mais
pas plus qu'au judo pas plus qu'au
karaté pas plus convoque en fait
lorsque le monde entier le pratiquait le
MMA était interdit en France autorisé
depuis trois ans ce sport de combat
spectaculaire attire aussi le regard
pour ses affrontements au sol le
principe du MMA c'est combat total donc
debout on commence debout et ça finit au
sol la plupart du temps donc on doit
retrouver une situation d'accord le but
c'est c'est de se mettre en sécurité
donc la gare
les genoux si on peut pour pouvoir
repousser créer de la distance
et pouvoir se relever au cas où protège
dents protège-tibia loin de son image
sulfureuse à Saran la majorité des
adhérents pratiques à MMA de loisirs on
sait qu'on peut faire mal à l'autre au
final très vite s'instaure les limites
comment on arrive à frapper l'autre des
fois le geste va un peu plus vite que la
pensée ou il avance sur le geste ça peut
toucher mais j'ai jamais vu d'accident
ici en un an un loisir qui n'empêche pas
d'aller jusqu'au bout de l'effort
une certaine dose de dopamine qu'on
cherche qu'on cherche un entraînement et
que j'arrive pas à retrouver dans
d'autres sports j'en ai essayé beaucoup
mais ce goût cette cette saveur qu'on a
à la fin d'entraînement étant épuisé
c'est c'est possible que dans le sport
de combat
en un an le club de l'agglomération
orléanaise compte près de 130 adhérents
un succès qui ne faiblit pas de quoi
espérer peut-être un jour l'arrivée du
fameux octogone la cage dans laquelle se
déroule les combats de MMA